good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday we are
so close to the end of the week
things are just flying by there's so
much going on so much news to discuss we
are so happy to be back here
hope everyone is having an amazing
morning so far if you're not having an
amazing morning
it's not too late to turn it around you
know what they say turn the beat around
left two hip percussions
how are you doing i'm good not as well
as you apparently
well actually i got a lot of dms
yesterday that the energy we brought to
the beginning of the show
was so energetic and electrifying so i
thought that we would try to recreate it
i mean you really can't recreate like
natural magic but that's what i'm trying
to do today
well that's claudia that's beautiful i
so appreciate it i agree with you this
week is sort of whizzing on by we're
like so close to the end it's
so utterly exciting two more days till
we sleep in that's just how i live my
life like i wake up every morning on the
wrong side of the bed because i'm not a
morning person
and i'm just like three more days until
i can sleep in two more days well two
more days till we can sleep in but then
we're that much closer to yom kippur
which is obviously devastating
obviously but you have to
change your perspective because no like
obviously i'm not looking forward to the
fast but i am looking forward to
repenting
for my sins yeah actually um something
about yom kippur i think because the day
is
so hard that it actually makes it really
real and i
really feel in a lot of ways like it's a
totally clean slate for the year
and i've just been so aware like since
the holidays started like of the things
that i do like i really have a gossip
problem and it's like
it's a really big problem but when it's
also like my job and i get paid to do it
it's also really hard to stop
yeah no it's definitely hard to stop but
the other thing i was going to say about
this week that i think is just making it
like a little bit fantastic and
and special is that it's such a regular
week like this is a week we would have
had a year ago you know what i mean yes
we're wearing masks but
i feel like for the first time in a
really long time this is just a regular
work week
i i do feel that and that's exciting i
can see how you could say something like
that yesterday i went to the live method
wow very exciting so i'm sore today but
i've got to get my [ __ ] in checks i am
wearing new toast merch that will be
available pretty soon so very exciting
i'm wearing zara
oh my god of course you are of course i
am and you're wearing chanel earrings
that jackie and i
on a random saturday a beautiful 2019
saturday took our men shopping and
forced them to buy us earrings
i have worn the earrings approximately
300 times and this is the first time
i've ever seen you wear this this is the
second time i've worn them because every
time i wear them then like i lose them
for a while and then i find them again
and i just really wanted to wear them
and i had this new turtleneck so i just
thought it would be
a cute moment let me know how that went
absolutely sensational and just a
message out there to all the people
listening
um if you're looking for you know your
significant other to buy you something
chanel earrings are less expensive than
you think yeah because they're costumes
so they were like 300 each which i feel
like is something reasonable you can ask
your partner to get for you for sure but
then it's also like because they're
costume they're actually like
three hundred dollars too expensive yeah
they're like players
so you know you're not getting what you
pay for but
you're getting chanel yeah from the love
of your life hopefully
so yeah we have a lot to talk about
today i've continued my
selling sunset sunset journey you've
finished your journey i have as far as
i'm i know thus proving that i'm a low
life with nothing to do yesterday and
like you live a busy fabulous i actually
got really busy yesterday and i didn't
get to get in bed and watch tv until
like normal time
like eight o'clock um but i tried to
catch up with you as much as i could so
i got through
to the episode where christelle and
justin
are splitsville which was just like a
crazy thing to catch on camera and
i've been doing a little bit of research
because part of me like
obviously wants to think that this is
like the oh my god i have something
unbelievable to tell you i'm so glad i
remember this i wrote it down but i
couldn't remember
um literally yesterday we're talking
about telling suntet about like the one
house in the hollywood hills that we've
been to
um where we went to a party and like
that's how much
and that's how much we know about the
hollywood hills well so we went to a
party there it is owned by a celebrity
and i found out through one of my
friends in la that that house is being
sold
next season on selling sunset yep oh my
god that is that crazy
that is so crazy that's so crazy
literally la is so small
there's five houses there's five people
so small um so i feel like we should
just hold off on recapping because i'm
fully done i don't want to spoil
anything for you and tomorrow will just
be like
selling sunset extravaganza part two
okay even though i'm so busy today i'm
gonna
make time to finish it i probably only
have three more episodes the episodes
are also
incredibly short and there's only eight
in a season and like i respect that i
love when
netflix respects our time extremely
snackable yeah very snackable
yeah but we're recording the redheads
today so
if you have questions make sure to email
them to the redheadsbookclub gmail.com i
have to put together the outline for the
show i'm like running a little behind on
that
but um the book came with reader's guide
questions so that's always helpful
you don't even know you don't even know
like trying to find
book club questions or make my own up
but like i'm terrible so
such like a middle-aged housewife let me
come up with my book
book club questions no totally but i'm
also just like a teacher like planning
my lesson yeah like your um
what do they call it syllabus my
syllabus snatchler learn your lesson you
know what the word syllabus like
actually gives me ptsd like i haven't
heard or said that word in years and i
never want to hear it again like
like the curriculum was like so hard for
me like i was just not like a smart
child and like oh my god it just it
brings me back to a really dark place
like syllabus no but syllabus day
what's syllabus day oh my god where you
just walk you go to all your classes and
you just get your syllabus like there's
no learning
is in college yeah so you just have like
10 minute classes on the first day
syllabus day
i don't think uh and you're just getting
your syllabus so there's no work that
you needed to have done
that you should have known about i don't
think we had that at nyu i mean it's
also the thing okay
still this week this week oh my god
crazy okay so it's very possible like we
did have it at nyu because like i said i
wasn't the most engaged shooting it
would have been the sort of thing that
you actually didn't even
show up like you didn't go to so you
didn't get to enjoy like
the shorter classes right you know the
feeling of okay
there's no homework yet yeah well
actually at nyu
in the first two weeks i really um don't
you don't have that much class because
the uh you can switch in and out of
classes for first year
semester so i actually used to not go to
class until the beginning of the third
week
because they didn't know like i just
couldn't say like i just enrolled you
know
yes this is true it is like genuinely a
miracle that i graduated
yeah it's a genuine miracle miracles
happen miracles happen
once in a while that's a great song it
is
you know settling sunset has really
great songs too okay so
my theory on the music from selling
sunset is it sounds like it's all saying
by the same
like group is it do they have like one
band that they contract to make music
because it okay
it sounds like vanderpump rules la music
that's a good idea
i actually looked up one of the songs
because i wanted to listen to it so i'll
look up another one there's no way that
that's the case because
i really feel it's not a job like making
music for one show oh the other thing i
was
trying to say before i remember the
thing about the house is that
the creators of the hills are the
creators of selling sunsets so part of
me now is just like dissecting it
are they real real estate agents i know
that mary is because mary's instagram
i've been like getting messages and
stuff that it's not real they're actors
playing real estate like yeah i don't
really care because i'm still a good
show
i'm turning a blind eye yeah turning but
i think i'm gonna have a burgers and
botox themed birthday party
love it quinn and out that was she's so
cute she's a genius she's everything of
the sort
and the more i watch like the more firm
i am in my stance and people said that
we would change their
third season and i just have to say i'm
all the way through and my thoughts on
christine have only not changed
intensified intensified yeah for sure i
don't know what y'all are talking about
i am more sure than ever that she's the
queen like
yeah okay so i'll finish it we'll talk
about it oh my god so i got
so many messages of who amanza is
vanessa zore
jessica zore sorry vanessa from gossip
girl alicia keys i don't see it but
that's like the grand
consensus gal gadot yeah i see that
i said katie from potomac i kind of see
that
very much reminds me of katie from photo
make someone message me zoe kravitz
zoe kravitz no it's really jessica's or
like
100 no but it's also like everyone is
literally five people put in one
oh yeah because i also got so many
people who thought that amanda looks
like
luanne de la salle oh my god i got that
too and i'm like okay
some people have just different eyes a
hundred percent because people think i'm
crazy and i know
i know what i saw yeah but like you can
see something so wholeheartedly and like
really truly in your soul believe it and
like nobody agrees sarah foster that
it's a good comparison so people agreed
with me on sarah foster
and that picture that you chose for the
instagram was like so unfair because
really it was a photo where she looked
like christina aguilera and erica jane
oh and that's not a photo that i would
have chosen like to say that she looks
like er because when she does that like
dida von t's
glam sort of look that's not when she
looks like aaron foster
okay well sarah i just have to say that
i've like worked so hard looking for a
picture like just to try and help
your hypothesis be proven like i was i
was trying to make it a level playing
field oh that's
that's so kind of you also uh christine
reminds me of alex cooper from call her
daddy
no i saw that too i don't see it at all
honestly the more that i watch the more
like concrete i am in my belief that
she's literally erica jane it's so crazy
and also she's now season three she's
starting to remind me of
you're never you're not gonna agree with
me at all but i just have to put it out
there because
it was like i just have to say what i
saw um
natalie halcrow from not live oh my god
you are so bad at this like no i'm not
i'm able to see
past hair color by the way so am i
literally her face her mannerisms are so
erica jane in season three
she wears a few scenes she does like a
really like no makeup makeup look and
she looks absolutely stunning and she's
still
literally looks like erica jane and
christine aguilera okay fine
i said what i said you said what you
said you did so
so as we said our selling sunset recap
will be tomorrow so
we will stop talking about it and you
know who mary reminds me of
someone awful um you would know her from
entourage
dana but i know her from constance
yes what quinn from unreal she just has
like that intense
energy and short haircut like running
around what's her name constance
zimmerman
i think so something like that she's
she's that agent dana of course um
dana gordon yeah she's actually one of
my literal favorite characters
that's who she reminds me in entourage
and now she's also in shameless
and um literally one of the worst calls
i've ever heard in my life
and a disgrace to calls i'm able to see
past
just the physicality it's so much more
than that actually from the
metaphysicality when we're
comparing like what people look like
it's literally only about the
physicality no but like some
people just have the same
energy it's energy it's okay energy
okay okay so i said what i said
take it or leave it so there was no tv
on last night ever since watching
selling sunset i literally have not
switched back to input one like i've
been on
on my apple tv so hard but tonight is
the finale of real housewives of new
york so i will be on my cable tonight
and keeping up with the kardashians is
on i actually have such a busy night
tonight
just like so crazy back to the good old
days back to the grind
back to the grind that's what us
hustlers say
i actually like to me people who use the
word like grind and hustle like are the
least hard-working people
in the country like it's just like gotta
get up there get a grind gotta hustle
yeah gotta rise and grind
if you actually spend time working and
not talking about how much you're
hustling like i actually think you'd be
more successful yeah i
actually just like don't vibe with that
whole hustle culture no like the
phrase like rise and grind reminds me of
like robbie hates
yeah no a hundred percent like and i
know that there's people who like love
those types of podcasts that are like
motivational and like those instagram
accounts and they literally
are so like motivational that they
literally create events like people come
like they think
like all these events it's literally
like a cult like i just
i've never been inspired by like hustle
culture like just go to work
yeah yeah i don't know i do feel like
that sort of
bullshittery is dying down where like
those instagram captions and stuff like
but i have been following some
inspirational instagram accounts and let
me tell you i'm inspired i'm actually
not even kidding tell us some of your
favorites i'm always reading
her quotes these quotes that come across
my feed my favorite one is third eye
thoughts
like it'll just tell me about it it'll
just get you in your thoughts and it's
not
it's yeah it's inspirational quotes but
like not like
love like you're used to like they're
not you know they don't rhyme
and they're just thoughts follow their
eye thoughts check it out let me read
one someone who acts like they hate you
will never love you that's not what i'm
talking about yeah i'm literally just
just choosing like random ones okay
take a moment to stop and celebrate how
far you've already come
savor it be proud you have done
amazingly well and you deserve to pause
and just feel good about it
that's so true i actually love that yeah
there's just so many good nuggets there
so check it out
check it out um so lots of news to
discuss i think we should just i think
we should just jump right in head first
head first into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and unfortunately i got a call from my
doctor my rdh is back
um but they did say that they said that
there's a cure and the cure is letting
absolutely everyone on the planet know
that today's episode is brought to you
by liquid iv
you all probably know liquid iv for
their popular hydration mix
and they've just launched their newest
line the energy multiplier
with roughly 100 milligrams of clean
caffeine it is the perfect coffee
replacement and an all-natural
alternative
to processed energy drinks for a
sustained energy boost throughout the
day
so if you're groggy when you wake up and
coffee isn't your jam or you're trying
to like wean off coffee i've actually
never
been into coffee i've tried like over
the years to get into it but it's just
not my thing
um and i've been using the energy
multiplier and energy multiplier since
we told you guys about it like a few
months ago and i feel like it's just a
perfect replacement for me and people
who are trying to get off caffeine
um and if you are like a groggy morning
person
i think that this actually might be the
product for you
over half of americans report that they
struggle with daily fatigue
some of those signs can include
decreased focus a lack of motivation
poor mood so with the liquid iv energy
multiplier you can upgrade your vibe and
reach your constant state of awesome
they have premium matcha and green
energy blend they taste delicious and
provide a lasting energy boost
throughout the day
it's a healthier alternative to
traditional energy drinks and coffee
and liquid iv has no artificial flavors
or preservatives
it's extremely it comes in an extremely
convenient packaging and
it can power your morning fuel long days
at work and provide a boost for those
tough workouts
liquid iv is also on a mission to change
the world they're donating 3.7 million
servings in response to coven 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military
so with your purchase you can know that
your money is actually doing some good
as well which is
also fabulous liquidity is available
nationwide at costco
you can also get 25 off if you go to
liquidive.com and use the code toast at
checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use promo code toast
at liquidive.com start fueling your
adventures today at liquidity.com
promo code toast sign on fuel your
adventures
fuel okay first story some very happy
news gigi hadid is a mom the supermodel
welcomes a baby girl
with boyfriend zane malik gigi and zayn
are parents
they welcome their first child together
zayn announced on wednesday he wrote
our baby girl is here healthy and
beautiful to try to put into words how i
am feeling right now would be an
impossible
task um okay so i feel like this
happened really fast like just the whole
pregnancy because she wasn't like
sharing that much so i just kind of had
forgotten about it yeah i don't know it
actually
doesn't feel so fast because i feel like
she was one of the earlier quarantine
pregnancy announcements and now like
we've been in
quarantine for seven months and yeah
that's true
i mean the thing with um with just like
the world right now is you know a year
ago maybe a little over like we were
reporting on her and tyler cameron
so it's just like we have come so far
you're gonna go there and i just feel
like quarantine and i was having this
discussion like with my friends
um when we went to dinner this week just
talking about how like people's
priorities have really really shifted
and quarantine has really
made people like see what's important i
feel like a lot of people are like
settling down more there were a lot of
quarantine pregnancies and so this is
just proof like so much can change in
two years yeah in one year yeah i don't
remember when like no they were dating
it does it was like the old studio right
but
it was like fall i literally think it
was this time last year crazy
great i think it was like august crazy
really crazy i'm really happy
for them there was like speculation that
she had had her baby and people were
predicting but i'm glad that they
shared it in their own time and i look
forward
to seeing this beautiful baba what i
thought was interesting was that like
the actual announcement was on
zayn's twitter um and i feel like that's
just uncommon like for the husband or
the
man to make the announcement and not the
mom but
they've always done their own thing and
i feel like they're going to continue to
do that
i'm curious what the baby's name is
going to be i know i'm really interested
this baby has
great nails that's what everyone was
pretty much commenting on zayn put up a
picture of him holding the baby's hand
and like the baby literally has acrylic
nails
she has a french manicure yeah like but
natural
very lovely very nice so it's really
sweet they're like um
they're like like all grown up you know
i feel like when they first started
dating they were like kids and there was
like all the drama
joe jonas one direction like all that
drama but now they're just like adults i
feel old
because like we're their age yes and i
don't have a baby yes i agree with that
no it's very exciting happy news happy
news for the couple
some more happy news lizzo lands her
first vogue cover
she looks like literally so beautiful
we'll post it on our instagram
it's just like so simple like i feel
like a lot of the times when she does
red carpets or um photo shoots like it's
a lot of like outfits and purses and
makeup
and this is just like simple red dress
she looks so glamorous
so glamorous thanks to her stage
presence lyrics and overall attitude to
life
not to mention her famous flute lizzo
has become a global success story and
now she's being celebrated with her
first
vogue cover feature the 32 year old
performer graces the october issue in a
ruffled scarlet frock by valentino
the detroit born star was styled for her
appearance by fashion director and
stylist carlos nazario and photographed
by music video director
and multi-hyphenate producer hype
williams the interview was conducted by
jamaican american poet essayist
playwright claudia
rankine it was my it was claudia and
lizzo also enlisted her go-to glam squad
alex mayo for makeup and shelby swain
for hair
this is perhaps the first time in the
magazine's history where all talent and
creative involved in the cover shoot
are bipoc wow
i mean okay so first of all i just as
like a chubby girl like lizzo is like my
leader and to see someone who like looks
like you on the cover of vogue like this
is just unheard of vogue like they're so
not like that
and i just love lizzo like breaking down
walls breaking barriers and like it's
just so fabulous and
she's so deserving like her success is
crazy like she was living in her car two
years ago like she's had unbelievable
success and this is just like
so crazy this is stunning it's so crazy
yeah really really it's like it's an
iconic cover
yes it's a very like old hollywood
glamour and i feel like
i mean especially now with you know
people doing at home photo shoots for
magazine givers it's been a while since
we got like a show-stopping cover
but it's i feel like it's also been a
while since we've gotten an iconic cover
where we're gonna look back on this for
so long yeah no this is definitely like
a really really big deal like for
everyone
yeah also a vogue cover comes with um 73
questions
oh yeah so lizzo it has a 73 questions
video we haven't watched it yet but i'm
so i think it's i think it's going to be
great and all the cover stars get 73
questions and
it's always really interesting but vogue
also does like 73 questions with like a
bunch of other people
and they're just like like boring
actresses and like to be honest it's
cool to see the inside of their house
but like their answers are so lame like
it kills me
and like i have a feeling lisos will be
incredibly interesting and not boring
and for that we have no choice but to
stand no choice but to stand also
speaking of vogue i saw addison rey did
like one of those um bathroom mirror
like makeup skin things i you told me
which is
so crazy and she's also announced
yesterday she's gonna be on ellen today
that that sounds so crazy to me that she
did one of those videos like i honestly
and i think she's so deserving and i
want to watch it and i think she's great
at makeup
but i feel like they give those videos
to everyone and then even sometimes they
slap a french vogue on there
to give it to someone even you know
smaller i guess it's just like
i i think it's so crazy because i don't
know i just
it's one thing to be like so viral and
it's another thing to be so famous and i
feel like over the last few months like
addison wright has like officially
transitioned from like a
viral star to like a tick uh to a
celebrity
and it's just crazy to see like all
these traditional things happening for
her and i by the way i
love her and i'm so here for it i
actually think she's a really really
good role model for kids agreed but if
vogue
and this is like one of their biggest
digital series is this makeup thing and
they do
try and stay current yeah and you know
keep up with the kids and if they're not
doing it with addison ray
yeah what are they doing yeah i'm very
curious to see her on ellen today
yes i'm curious to hear what you have
i'm
curious for you to watch it and let me
know what happened yeah i mean i
thought i wasn't gonna be watching ellen
anymore but she pulled me back in wow
she pulled you back in
she did interesting i mean i'm not gonna
like turn on my tv like a sociopath i'll
watch it online
okay ellen tube okay next story kristen
cavallari
breaks her silence on her divorce from
jay cutler oh
the hardest decision i've ever made so
kristin cavallari
is i think on the cover of people this
month she's talking to people
exclusively all about
what happened with her and jay she said
that they had been struggling privately
for years and they made a conscious
effort to keep their marriage what was
hidden
she said i always thought it was
interesting when people would refer to
us as couple goals
she was like if you guys only knew as
their marriage hit a crisis point during
filming last season we definitely kept a
lot of stuff private she says
producers saw stuff but they didn't put
it in the show which is good because i
don't want my kids to ever see that
yeah while their split seemingly came
out of the blue
it didn't happen overnight she says we
tried really really hard for years and
years
it was the hardest decision i ever made
i still care about him so much and talk
to him almost every day
we have three kids together he's going
to be in my life forever
i mean like to me i feel i might be
unique in
in this feeling where it's like i don't
think that celebrities owe us an
explanation on absolutely everything
that goes on in their lives
and i i do think probably she did this
for like you know good press and stuff
but like it feels weird like i don't
really need to know what happened in
your marriage like it's almost like
information it's like a little too
intimate for me
and she's like spreading it all for this
spread well she's not spreading it all i
think she
i like not to be so like cynical but i
i'm sure she got a huge payday
yeah for this people magazine article to
talk about her relationship i think
for a lot of people you know who watch
the show
jay and kristen are a couple goals and
then all the they were in the bahamas
and the next day
right it didn't add up so people even
though i agree like we don't
no one owes us celebrities don't owe the
public an explanation on
absolutely everything and sometimes i
feel like when people demand it it's
like so
rude yeah but obviously people are
curious
and yeah and they had a reality show so
like that's the world that they're in
but
i just i i think i consider them to be a
little bit more famous than they
actually are just because like
he's so successful like she's like part
of an iconic show like
i don't think of them as like reality tv
like trash like i do the rest of these
people you know yes
i agree with that and she also said that
that's why
she's like glad to not be doing another
season of her show because it would have
to be about
what happened like she doesn't want her
kids to like see her talking [ __ ] about
their dad
i agree it's really amazing how she
really does everything and i know
most people and celebrities try and do
this but like she does everything like
to protect her children and like
that they've she had a popular show for
three years and we've never
seen them like she won't even do a next
season of the show because it would mean
you know speaking ill of their dad
right i really respect it me too i
actually think um
there are very few people who have
actually hidden
like what their kids like look like and
like sonia the fact that sonia morgan
has never once shown her kid
on the show not through her own choice
because i'm sure the morgans don't let
her but like the fact that we literally
don't even know what she looks like is
so crazy same with bethany
yeah no i mean it's i think it's really
great if you can it's like i have a ton
of respect for the people who
choose to do it and who can pull it off
yeah and kristen cavallari has really
pulled it off
while also like bearing all for
tradition which is
which is a lot yeah so i wonder if
she'll join the reboot of the hills
probably not really your own show and
also i think she would do a house in
nashville so she doesn't even live
in l.a also what's so crazy is like i'm
reading this article and it's like you
know five months ago they announced
their split and that's like
five months ago already that literally
feels like last month and that's five
months of our life like we will
literally never ever ever get back
five months of our life with nothing to
show for it nothing
so sad so sad it said when quarantine
news like develops then you remember
where you were when you first heard it
because it feels like yesterday but it
was like low-key march yeah
it is hate to see it hate to see it next
story some happy couple news emma stone
is married to dave mcrae
what i didn't see this emma stone and
dave mcrae are married after
photos of them surfaced this week
showing the couple wearing matching gold
bands
a source told page six they have
definitely tied the knot oh so there's
no like vogue
pictures or anything no but they had
previously postponed their march wedding
amid the pandemic
and i guess at some point between then
and now they made it official and who
was he
unclear what's his name dave mcrae it's
a lucky man dave mcrae he's a former
segment director
on snl former segment director okay i
wonder if they met on the set there
little scarlett and collins wonderfully
double date
um okay this is interesting i literally
didn't even know she had a boyfriend
so good for her yeah i feel like there
are a lot of people who are like gonna
be disappointed by this because i think
a lot of like millennial like movie
buffs like live for her and ryan gosling
like they're always in movies together
like that's so funny because if you have
said to me like who would
who are we living for her with i
wouldn't have even known
i think i mean i don't i respect his
relationship with eva
but i think a lot of people like ship
them oh
i don't i feel like most people would
ship ryan gosling and rachel mcadams
i mean like 15 years ago but like we've
got to move on
yeah but what we ship them from la la
land and they've done a few movies
together they have crazy stupid love
right there was like four years where
like every year they did a movie
together and it was kind of like la la
la la lady gaga and bradley cooper where
it was like you stan you shipped a
couple but
yes they just did it year after year
yeah but it was also like jennifer
lawrence bradley cooper where they
like did a lot of movies together and
it's like i feel like jennifer lawrence
didn't like bradley cooper but he liked
her like that was just the vibe that i
got
i have no information i just i just read
people's body language
and that was the vibe that i got like i
actually think she's genuinely too good
for him
you think so yeah i think that they
would be great together
no i just i i didn't get the vibe at all
like
actually i was on a plane with her once
i actually attended a wedding that she
was at and
i could just tell from her energy she
was telling me telepathically
i bradley cooper wanted that's fine he
didn't get it i didn't get i don't know
she just that's what i read like okay
and you know
i'm not saying it's correct but i'm also
not saying it's incorrect got it that
was just how i read the situation okay
and i'm very intuitive
you are that you are very okay well
fifth and final story are two real
housewives
bits of news just gonna close the book
on some things we've been talking about
and i
i am housewives fatigued now um i'm i am
but i was interested in the follow-up on
especially one of these stories
there's some there's a and b okay a liam
mcsweeney bumped
ten thousand dollars per episode for her
second year on roni which is what as we
said is a reasonable
salary for someone of her stature what
was her salary before
3 000 yeah and they probably offered
five and she landed at 10 and that's why
you negotiate ladies know your worth
yes and hopefully this will elevate
everything about her life you know from
her apartment
to just the overall you know the
finishings in her house like just
overall i'm hoping that for better
finishing yeah for better for better
hardware
also so we can put that to bed okay
happy to see
her get what she deserves and that
she'll be back season two
of leah season 50 of the house
kris jenner says she's not joining real
housewives of beverly hills oh no
there's just too much going on in my
life but kathy hilton i saw this on like
a comments by celebs page and by the way
the comments by celebs
starter uh founders are on lord
elizabeth's podcast and lauren said it
was an amazing episode i haven't gotten
a chance to listen to it yet so check
that out
but um they pointed out like someone
left a comment on kathy hilton's
page of like about housewives and she
said i'm thinking about it
that bothers me but that means the
conversations like are true like it's
being had
you think or maybe she's like thinking
about calling them maybe she saw
you know the demand for her and so she's
thinking about calling them up and
asking for an audition but i do think
that they've definitely been in
communication with her like
via kyle and i actually think like if
she joined housewives like it would
bother kyle
it would be like a melissa and teresa
situation oh i think so too
territorial for the spotlight kyle you
know feels like she built this show
and it would be it would be good i think
so too but this is what chris had to say
um about going on beverly hills she said
i think i would do it
just to go on once in a while and be
with my friend kyle richards but as far
as me doing a show like that regularly
regularly there's just too much going on
in my life and they do not need a kris
jenner on that show
they are doing just fine yeah i mean
hypothetically
would i love to see chris jenner on
bravo yes but i never thought this was a
real
yeah but so for every situation it's
like holding out hope just wanted to let
you know
um your dreams have been crushed but
maybe she'll continue to like show up to
kyle's
house and then we can like have her in
the same frame as erica james yeah
and that's just that's just fun i mean
i'm realistic i literally never thought
that this was an actual possibility like
that was it was never coming to fruition
but people out there maybe
you know we're delusional and thought
that but i didn't yeah
i didn't i did not either so i'm really
hoping that you know
now that each franchise is cementing
their next cast
we can move on yeah i just think there's
been a lot of housewives news because
it's like a real transitional period
in housewives history like og's being
let go and it's just um
all converging like at the same time
yeah and that's what it is
and that's what it is so
okay we have uh keeping up with the
kardashians and real housewives of new
york city recap for you tomorrow
there was no tv on last night so i
believe that's the end of our show
i believe it's the end of our show i
need to go home and watch selling sunset
to finish it by tomorrow so that we can
really go in on our thoughts yes
and get ready for the redheads book club
you know it's never too late to join the
episode it doesn't drop
till next week are you okay i'm just
like burpee
and emotional and emotional
um the episode doesn't drop until next
week so you actually have like the full
week you can read the book it's
so if you love the morning toast like
you will love this book because it's all
about
early 2000's girl band living and
it's it was a trip down memory lane for
sure
um also tons of new episodes of all of
our tnn and the book is called oh
right sorry the unwrap no i i forgot the
unraveling of cassidy holmes by alyssa
sloan um all of our tnn shows have new
episodes this week margaret josephs
raven alexis
lauren and the snatcher returns in
october with the new season of the
bachelor so it's never been a better
time to follow toast news network on
instagram to keep up with all the latest
tnn news and with that i bid you a
jew thank you so much for listening to
the morning shows monday morning show
where we
deliver the fast side stories that you
need to know every morning monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we are also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i ironbasebox we
are now newly available on amazon music
so find us wherever you find your
podcast the morning toast and leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much and we'll see you tomorrow
for friday
bye goodbye goodbye
you